hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions a seemingly
simple maths question was given to a
class of seven year olds as homework but
it left most pupils and even their
parents scratching their heads
that's according to Nathan rau of the
express what's the problem
there are 73 red blue and green marbles
in a jar there are twice as many red
marbles as blue marbles
there are 19 more blue marbles than
green marbles how many green marbles are
there now remember to find a solution
for seven-year-olds using no algebra can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution so first I
would write out each sentence as a
separate line the strategy I would use
is to work backwards using trial and
error that means start with the very
last sentence and work to the first
sentence
so let's visually do that we'll start
with the very last sentence how many
green marbles are there well we don't
know so we'll make an educated guess
let's suppose there is one green marble
the next sentence tells us there are 90
more blue marbles than green marbles
that would mean there are 20 blue
marbles the next sentence says there are
twice as many red marbles as blue
marbles meaning there would be two times
20 or 40 red marbles now from our guests
of one how many total marbles are there
there would be one plus 20 plus 40 which
is 61 so we know that one can't be the
answer because the total has to be 73 so
we're going to make a larger guess now
as you work through a few options you'll
eventually get to green is equal to 4
this would mean there are 23 blue
marbles and then 46 red marbles making
for a total of 73 marbles which exactly
matches the given information so this is
the correct answer and there are four
green marbles now this may seem like a
strange way to solve this problem but
it's actually not that different from
the way we would normally solve it using
algebra we would again work backwards
from the last sentence we would say that
there are G green marbles then there are
19 plus G which is the number of blue
marbles then we would say that R is
equal to 2 B because red is equal to
twice the number of blue marbles at this
step we would need to simplify we can
put in B is equal to 19 plus G and we
need to distribute the 2 so we get that
R is equal to 38 plus 2 G finally we
have 73 marbles in total so we
substitute in 19 plus G for B and we
substitute in 38 plus 2 G for R we get
this equation which simplifies to B for
G is equal to 16 we can then solve that
G is equal to 4 so once again we get
there are 4 green marbles did you figure
it out thanks for watching these math
videos which can be watched for free on
youtube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
a hundred million views and the channel
has over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic presh and mind your decisions calm
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon thanks for watching and
thanks for your support